l' affaire grégory et la difficile et
minutieuse recherche de la vérité le
juge simon qu'instruit le dossier
corrige partiellement les commentaires
de la presse après son interview
accordée à la 5
je n'ai pas dit il de pistes nouvelles
dans cette affaire aujourd'hui un témoin
capital puisqu'il avait reçu le coup de
fil du corbeau un témoin capital a été
entendu par les gendarmes
michel villemin après son audition de
près de 6 heures hier a été soumis à une
expertise graphologique josé gang en
baisse 10 heures ce matin les gendarmes
de la section de recherches de dijon se
présente au domicile de michel villemin
le frère de jean-marie étrange visite
puisse kiev ces mêmes gendarmes l'ont
déjà entendu pendant près de six heures
à bruyères étrange visite qui permet
toutes les hypothèses
peut-être les gendarmes sont simplement
venus lui remettre une nouvelle
convocation ou peut-être souhaitent ils
avoir quelques précisions notamment
quant au test de la dictée que michel a
subi hier pour comparer son écriture
avec celle du corbeau
car cette dictée a eu lieu elle est
confirmée par les parents de michèle
michel été soumis hier au test de
l'adapter c'est la logique des chefs
depuis dimanche on se croirait revenu
cinq ans en arrière les déclarations du
juge simon la présence de gendarmes
bourguignon changer de l' enquête sur le
terrain ont ravivé le souvenir du drame
du 16 octobre 84 1 s'il se passe quelque
chose dans les vosges le juge simon
l'entourent paradoxalement du plus grand
secret alors qu'il a promis des
rebondissements pour bientôt